what do I think about the try-hard
mentality I'm gonna answer that question
in today's episode of ask Evan so I got
a question for one of my youtube viewers
love you guys rui goooo who wrote in to
say hey Evan what are your thoughts on
the try-hard mentality so I'm not super
familiar with the try-hard mentality my
understanding of it is it's when you're
working really hard on something but
you're not seeing results it's kind of
like busywork you're working just to
work and you're not actually moving
forward on anything that you're doing
and so if that's what you're doing it's
not good but for any big goal that you
have you have to work really hard right
it's not just working smart it's working
smart and working hard and you have to
try really hard to make that happen and
I like to think of it in terms of not
having regrets in my life and feeling
like I gave everything I had to whatever
project I was working on i'ma give you
an example something that's happening
right now I'm in the process of
acquiring a business and as part of that
process I want to bring on a team leader
to help run a good chunk of the company
and at first he said no and I went home
and thought about I think well maybe
there's got to be another way to do it
you know I wanted to make sure that
every stone was was was turned over
every possible opportunity every
possible angle was explored I didn't
want to feel like there was some other
way that we could structure this deal to
make it work so he would say yes and so
you know two nights ago is up until five
in the morning structuring a deal we met
again last night and he was here at my
place until midnight working on another
deal and and it looks like we have
something in place you know maybe next
week i have a video to update you guys
and what's happening but it was all of
that work was because
you know even though he said no to start
I wanted to make sure just in my own
head that I I explored every single
angle every possible way to accomplish
my goal I tried and if he at the end of
that said no that's cool I would move on
and find somebody else and I get
somebody else to kind of run that
position but I didn't want to live the
rest of my life in regret thinking like
man what if I just tried this angle of
that angle or this angle right and
hoping that maybe that would have worked
out and so if you have a dream a lot of
times the most logical path or the path
that you think is going to work out
doesn't and so if you want to hit that
dream you've got to take detours you've
got to find other ways of saying you got
to take a different way to get there and
that comes from trying hard and doing a
lot of work to do it my second quick
thought on it is you want to do things
out of passion and you're not working
hard just to look like you're busy you
know make everybody look at you and say
well that guy's doing a ton of work but
you're you're working as a byproduct of
you being excited about something but
you've been passionate about something
when you love doing something it almost
doesn't feel like you're doing work
because you're still engrossed in it and
you have such a commitment level to it
and so I would focus not on how much
work you're doing but are you doing work
that you love because if you're doing
work that you love you're going to try
hard and do a good job of it and put in
the hours that you need to be successful
if you look at any successful
entrepreneur and track their growth it
came from putting in insane amounts of
hours working smart plus working hard
doing something that they love and so
those are my quick thoughts hopefully an
answer the question and continue to
believe so I'd love to know from you
guys what do you think about the try
hard mentality leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon